[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
quels impacts des plateformes numériques
sur les métiers et l'emploi
chauffeur livreur mais aussi traducteur
ou expert comptable l'ubs et risation de
la société est une réalité économique et
sociale qui concerne de plus en plus de
secteurs professionnels
le fonctionnement de ces plateformes
temps à remettre en cause notre modèle
économique et social
face à ce phénomène le sénat entend
jouer son rôle d' alerte en créant une
mission d'information sur l'ubs et
risation de la société
il s'agit d'un travail trans partisan
avec une présidente du groupe l'est
républicain
martin berthet et un rapporteur
communiste pascal savoldelli
pour appréhender la plateforme isation
de l'économie la mission d'information a
entendu plus de 60 personnes et ouvert
une consultation en ligne destiné à
toutes les personnes concernées
les auteurs du rapport qui est paru le
29 septembre 2021 constate tout d'abord
que pour soutenir une intense
concurrence par les prix ces entreprises
recourent en lieu et place de salariés à
des travailleurs juridiquement
indépendants
les plateformes réduisent de la sorte le
coût du travail par le transfert à leurs
travailleurs du risque économique et
social
la plateforme isation contribuer ainsi à
la polarisation du marché du travail
entre des travailleurs ayant librement
choisi ce statut et des travailleurs
faiblement qualifiés qui pâtissent d'une
situation de précarité
de plus les mécanismes d'incitation et
les systèmes de notation utilisé par les
plateformes place les travailleurs en
état de subordination
à long terme la multiplication de
plateformes de services aux particuliers
déstabilise les professionnels établis
sur ces marchés
sur la base de ce diagnostic
la mission d'information a formulé 18
propositions
elle souhaite notamment inscrire dans la
loi le principe d'une rémunération
minimale à la tâche
elle recommande en outre d'encadrer le
management algorithmique par exemple en
imposant aux plateformes de travail
l'effacement intervalles réguliers de
l'historique des notes attribuées par
les clients aux travailleurs qui les
utilisent
elle préconise aussi de garantir
l'intelligibilité des algorithmes pour
les travailleurs et leurs représentants
afin qu'il devienne un objet de
négociation collective
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]